What are you reading oh
nothing nothing really just uh
oh
well
Welcome back everyone this will be my morbius 2
teaser video apparently it's morbid time i hope
the internet is happy with what it's done because
look what sony has produced jared leto and sony
are just getting in on the fun apparently you
meme so hard the studio thought that everyone
loved the movie and just put it back in theaters
too so i'll explain what's going on and why jared
leto released this morbius 2 video and what's
really going on in sony's spider-man spin-off
movies this big sinister six movie that they're
making that they teased in the post-credits scene
so if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos because there
is a lot of spider-man coming i'm not sure how
i got here has to do with spider-man i think
i'm still figuring this place out but i think
a bunch of guys like us should team up so this
past week you probably saw jared leto posting this
morbius 2 video getting out on the fun first off
congratulations internet this is because of what
you did i hope you're happy with yourself i know
that look you're up to something what is it it's
more than time sony of course saw all the morbius
memes it's morbid time out in the wild and thought
that that meant that people loved it completely
missing the point of the memes apparently as all
the memes say they truly do believe in the morbius
sweep i believe the actual origin of the morbid
time meme was someone clowning on another person's
morbius just random post saying something about
morbius being in the final battle of avengers
end game and doing something really ridiculous
like snapping the infinity gauntlet instead of
iron man being ultra overpowered just some crazy
what if meant to clown on the morbius movie and
then after that it turned into a big pylon thing
with the general internet just posting all their
own memes so if you've seen the doctor strange ii
morbid time memes with morbius vs scarlet witch
like no one can stop her except for morbius that's
where the memes came from some of the jokes are
pretty solid i laugh pretty hard but sony legit
put the movie back in theaters yesterday it bombed
again predictably because if you knew what was
really going on you knew it was going to happen
first off like i said people just did not dig
the movie in general and sony mostly just took
the wrong meaning from all the meme posting and if
you look at those original morbius trailers from
a couple years ago at this point that's right
the movie was delayed multiple times a couple
years ago it looked like they might have had
at one time an interesting movie on their hands
they had all these easter eggs for the different
versions of spider-man and as confusing as it was
it actually became a pretty interesting thing
like oh okay this could have been really silly
but now i'm really interested to see the way they
explain all these different andrew garfield tobey
maguire and tom holland's spider-man easter
eggs along with the venom connections that all
seemingly kind of contradict each other they have
the tobey maguire daily bugle logo with his fond
they have black cat they have rhino which are both
andrew garfield's amazing spider-man characters
they also have the tobey maguire spider-man
suit in the tom holland murder plot points
from the mysterio storyline you also have the
inclusion of the mcu version the vulture he
was always going to be in the movie in slightly
different ways then you have all the venom easter
eggs where like in the movie he literally
says i am venom who the hell are you man
originally the movie was going to use the mcu
vulture in a completely different part of the
movie in a completely different context so
it just seemed like they had a very different
version of the movie at one time that could have
been a little bit more interesting what wound up
happening is the movie was delayed multiple times
like all the big marvel movies and all the big
spider-man movies and after one of the last round
of delays they moved spider-man no way home to
the end of the year it earned so much money like
crazy amount of money even without china the movie
earned almost 2 billion dollars in the middle
of the pandemic so that was all going on while
people were still really worried about the virus
they still went to theaters because that movie was
so strong so what had happened is that originally
sony had intended for morbius to be this smaller
movie just like a standard character origin kind
of like the first venom movie it was always meant
to take place on the same earth as the venom
movie but they had all these plans to connect
it more fully with what was going on in spider man
no way home and they were going to release it much
closer to spider man no way home but then sony
decided that spider man no way home was making
so much money like way more than they expected
amidst the pandemic so they just decided to let
that ride and delayed morbius again and they got
so worried about hurting spider man no way homes
box office juice that they just removed all the
spider-man stuff from the morbius movie except
for that post-credits scene and turned it into a
completely different type of movie and waited a
couple more months to release it after people had
stopped buying tickets for spider-man no way home
so much so no big surprise people just kind of
lost interest in the movie about the character
that isn't super popular like venom and apparently
wasn't going to be as connected to everything
anymore with all the cuts that they made and
just delayed so many times so sony really kind of
clowned themselves on this they really did this to
themselves personally i would have started morbius
off in a more shared universe type of situation
like they did with spider-man in the marvel mcu
movies but the whole thing with the morbius 2
teaser video that jared leto released that script
for morbius 2 is mostly meant to be a joke like
he's getting in on the meme sony wouldn't actually
title the movie it's morbid time and the person's
name on the script bartholomew cubbins is actually
a fictional dr seuss character bartholomew cubbins
is a fictional page in a hero of two of dr seuss's
books the first movie still hasn't earned its full
box office back yet it hasn't earned its marketing
budget so they're still considering it a loss
but jared leto pretty decent actor if you give
him the right material and he did sign a multiple
picture contract for the shared spider-man movies
before he did the morbius film so you don't need
to worry about morbius 2 so much what they'll
probably do is just have jared letos morbius show
up as a major character in the sinister six movie
that they're working on right now with michael
keaton's vulture character venom any of the other
characters that they introduced like the craven
character anyone knew from that madame web movie
that they're working on they've been making all
kinds of announcements about that in any other
spider-man spin-off character that they do or any
other new version of spider-man they introduce
because the whole pitch of that morbius
post-credits scene is that they're going after
spider-man or a version of spider-man so at some
point here they actually do have to have someone
in a spider-man suit that they all fight has to
do with spider-man i think now you're asking which
version of spider-man are they going to fight in
that movie tom hall and spider-man andrew garfield
spider-man tobey maguires or live-action miles
morales spider-man or even one of the versions
of spider-woman that it sounds like they're
also working on separately i did a couple
easter egg videos for this when they still had the
spider-man scenes in the more bass movie and in
all the trailers like i said morbius is meant to
be on a shared earth with venom same universe and
based on those easter eggs and all the trailers
they share more in common with andrew garfield's
amazing spider-man because there were a lot of
references to that during spider-man no way home
and it sounds like here during the morbius trailer
if it's been a while since you've seen amazing
spider-man 2 during that movie you might remember
they referenced morbius and venom specifically
along with a bunch of other teasers for other
characters and things buried in harry osborne's
ozcorp files like zoom and enhance here they
have a morbius project that they were working on
they had a venom project so had they made amazing
spider-man 3 with andrew garfield they would have
given him the venom symbiote during that movie and
he would have faced a version of the sinister six
as they teased in the post-credits scene but we
also would have seen a version of black cat show
up and then obviously they were trying to set
up a whole bunch of other spin-off movies too
now that andrew garfield has come back in a big
way during spider man no way home as a multiverse
spider-man spider-verse spider-man however you
want to think about him along with tobey maguire
but during the movie andrew garfield referenced
what sounded like a teaser for the venom symbiote
saga in his own universe like he talked about
being bitter and angry after gwen stacey died
becoming rageful not pulling his punches anymore
i fought a an alien made out of black goo
once oh no way i found alien too i want to fight
an alien that to me sounds like the setup for an
andrew garfield symbiote saga as if he was
explaining the plot of amazing spider-man 3
and that's also kind of why they called him
peter three like tom holland was peter one
tobey maguire was peter two andrew garfield
called himself peter 3 as a sort of wink at
amazing spider-man 3. so because there's all these
easter eggs and references mostly tying morbius to
andrew garfield's spider-man and it sounds like
had a plan a long time ago to introduce a version
of morbius in the amazing spider-man universe it's
always possible that sony brings andrew garfield's
spider-man back for more cameos as part of the
continuing sort of morbius venom universe that
they're building over on their side of things
so if it's meant to be any kind of spider-man
universe it would be amazing spider-man's universe
if he doesn't want to do that sinister six movie
they might swerve on his version and if they
don't say that it's a version of peter parker
like tom hall and tobey maguire don't do it early
theory is that they would probably just go with
a live-action version of miles morales because it
sounds like they're working up to doing that after
the animated spider-man across the spider-verse
movies they even had an easter egg for live-action
miles morales in spider-man homecoming we just
haven't actually seen him on screen in live action
wearing that spider-man suit yet they are working
on a spider-woman movie right now but you remember
in that morbius post-credits scene vulture
literally said spider-man not spider-woman so
they really want you to think it's going to be
a version of peter parker or potentially miles
morales the next actual big spider-man movie is
going to be spider-man across the spider-verse and
tom holland is supposed to be coming back for
spider-man 4. like sony has already said that
they're making it they're just trying to get
everybody to sign their deals so that they can
announce it and they also just confirmed that
they're in the middle of making venom three
so morbius also might wind up cameoing in
venom three but let me know in the comments
if they do not do morbius 2 which it sounds like
they won't where do you want to see that character
show up next remember there's like a billion
spider-man spin-off movies that sony is working
on right now so there's gonna be a lot of other
brand new characters in the next couple years
there'll be a bunch more marvel trailers next week
in another brand new marvel series that's starting
i'll do separate videos for that just like i
would for any other big disney plus marvel series
be sure to enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss that everyone click here for my brand
new thor love and thunder trailer video and click
here for my obi wan kenobi episode 4 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!